[Música]
bienvenidos Soy Pedro Nelson Ruiz por
Natalia Cabrera esto es aquí América y
Estos son nuestros temas para hoy
el gobierno de Estados Unidos trata de
blindarse ante el inminente fin del
llamado título 42 el próximo 11 de mayo
revisamos las medidas emitidas por la
administración de Joe biden que
analizamos qué tan efectivas llegarán a
hacer
las autoridades peruanas cometieron
graves violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos durante las protestas por la
destitución de Pedro Castillo Esa es la
conclusión del más reciente informe de
la cidh sobre la situación de derechos
fundamentales en el país suramericano
Tenemos reporte desde Lima
inicio en Cuba el tercer ciclo de
diálogos de paz entre el estado
colombiano y la guerrilla del eln un
acuerdo sobre un cese de hostilidades
bilateral es el tema que marca la agenda
miramos los hechos detrás de Por qué ha
sido tan difícil lograr un alto el fuego
con este grupo ilegal
nuestro tema principal nos lleva a
Estados Unidos el próximo 11 de mayo
llega a su fin el llamado título 42 una
controversial política emitida por los
centros de prevención de enfermedades
que tenía por objetivo de tener la
propagación del covid 19 desde marzo de
2020 dicha medida ha permitido expulsar
a los migrantes que de forma irregular
han intentado cruzar la frontera hacia
territorio estadounidense por lo que
pasó de ser una medida sanitaria a
convertirse en un Pilar de la política
migratoria de la entonces administración
de Donald Trump y parte de la de Joe
biden
durante el tiempo que ha estado en vigor
la oficina de aduanas y protección
fronteriza ha reportado las siguientes
cifras solo tomando en cuenta el título
42 en el año fiscal 2020 se registraron
206,783 encuentros en la frontera casos
que aumentaron en 2021 que ese año se
presentaron un millón 71.075 encuentros
en 2022 fueron un millón ciento tres mil
novecientos sesenta y seis y en lo que
va corrido del año fiscal 2023 se han
registrado cerca de
444.146 encuentros
ante el inminente fin de esta política
el gobierno de Joe biden ha emitido una
serie de medidas con las que busca
enfrentar el posible aumento de la
llegada de migrantes una de ellas es la
creación de los llamados centros de
procesamiento de inmigrantes en países
de América Latina las primeras naciones
donde se abrirán estos puestos para
aliviar la presión sobre la frontera sur
son Colombia y Guatemala el plan es que
desde estas locaciones se procesarán las
solicitudes de asilo antes que los
migrantes lleguen a la frontera entre
Estados Unidos y México pero las medidas
También tienen un componente de
seguridad el pentágono ante una petición
del departamento de seguridad nacional
aprobó el envío de un contingente de
1500 militares a la frontera Sur según
la Casa Blanca el personal ayudará en
labores administrativas y no ejercerán
funciones policiales ni tendrán contacto
con los migrantes
previamente hablamos con el analista
Internacional Erick Fajardo con quien
conversamos sobre el balance que dejan
los más de tres años que ha estado
vigente esta política
durante la pandemia no hubo que entienda
yo una sobredemanda de ingreso en los
Estados Unidos no es como que la gente
trató de venir huyendo de la pandemia
Pero hay una permanente pulsión una
permanente demanda de la gente por
ingresar al territorio norteamericano
que tiene que ver con razones históricas
socioeconómicas políticas eh culturales
incluso y y que bueno pues con el título
42 se frenó de alguna manera se frenó y
y se evitó que por lo menos hubiese al
mismo ritmo un ingreso de este
refugiados de desplazados de población
desplazada en los Estados Unidos en el
primer año luego fue completamente
inoperable inefectiva hasta para
contener el flujo migratorio generó
políticas dentro del estado mexicano que
bueno incrementaron la vulnerabilidad y
la violencia contra quienes intentaban
desplazarse hacia la frontera norte y de
ninguna manera diría yo que tampoco en
términos de contención del capital
humano fue fue efectiva como si hubiera
esperado pero sí seguramente al menos en
este aspecto en el aspecto de contener
la migración desenfrenada Sí sí tuvo un
relativo éxito durante el primer periodo
de tiempo Durante los primeros 18 meses
diría yo
Pero la pregunta acá es si serán
eficientes o efectivas las medidas
tomadas por la administración de Joe
biden para intentar blindarse ante una
eventual ola migratoria tras el fin del
título 42 Este es el análisis de Erick
Fajardo No creo que la migración o el
flujo migratorio sea una preocupación de
la Administración biden en este momento
la administración biden de una manera no
oficial por supuesto de una manera no
formal pero no ha hecho los mismos
esfuerzos que su predecesora por
intentar contener la oleada migratoria y
una cifra de uno punto nueve millones de
migrantes indocumentados que pudieron
pasar la frontera el año pasado y eso
muestra para mí entender Más allá de
falta de oficio en el cuidado de las
fronteras un cambio de orientación en la
política migratoria que tampoco que hay
que verla como un intento benévolo de
abrir la frontera Es simple y
sencillamente que creo que la
administración va a ir No va a ser una
prioridad de este contención en la
frontera en términos de política
doméstica de política del interior la
orden de terminar el título 42 fue una
decisión Del cdc una decisión técnica
que entendió que ya no era necesario
como mecanismo para intentar frenar el
Coby y desde mi punto de vista nunca fue
siquiera útil o nunca cumplió su
propósito desde el punto de vista médico
hoy día no se justifica por supuesto
todas maneras hay esos espacios de
retención de migrantes donde las
condiciones no son mucho mejores de las
que proveían términos humanitarios la
anterior administración creo que lo que
sí queda claro es que en ausencia del
título cuarenta y dos no se vislumbra
una política de estado al menos no una
mucho más sólida mucho más efectiva y
mucho más humana que la anterior
ahora vamos hasta Perú la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos en su
más reciente informe sobre el país
suramericano denunció graves violaciones
a los derechos fundamentales en el país
la cidh señaló que durante el estallido
social luego de la destitución de Pedro
Castillo se registraron masacres y
ejecuciones extrajudiciales desde Lima
nuestro corresponsal Francisco Zacarías
tiene los detalles la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
denunció en un informe graves
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
durante las protestas contra el gobierno
de la presidenta Dina boluarte y el
congreso producidas entre diciembre de
2022 y enero de 2023 el organismo acusó
un uso excesivo de la fuerza que causó
muertes heridos además señaló que las
muertes perpetradas por agentes
estatales podrían constituir ejecuciones
extrajudiciales así como masacres la
presidenta boluarte rechazó las
acusaciones y afirmó que los hechos
están siendo investigados por la
justicia peruana sin embargo familiares
de denuncian que los casos sobre las
muertes de más de 60 personas se
encuentran paralizadas acusan al
Ministerio Público de conformar un
equipo especial de Fiscales para
concentrar en Lima la investigación así
las investigaciones Fiscales en las
regiones están siendo trasladadas lo
cual altera lo poco que se había
avanzado los familiares afirman que esto
en vez de garantizar acceso a la
justicia es brindar impunidad a los
culpables y denuncian una presunta
maniobra para retrasar las
investigaciones al respecto a la fiscal
general de Perú Patricia Benavides ha
pedido tener confianza en la indagación
que realiza el equipo especial Mientras
tanto la fiscal general de este país
Investiga la presidenta Dina boluarte al
Primer Ministro Alberto tarola así como
a los ministros del interior y defensa
por los presuntos delitos de genocidio
homicidio calificado y lesiones graves
arrancó en Cuba el tercer ciclo de
diálogos de paz entre el gobierno
colombiano y la guerrilla del eln las
partes inician esta nueva etapa Con un
objetivo principal pactar un cc de
hostilidades bilateral veamos más en el
siguiente informe
silenciar El ruido de los fusiles Ese es
quizás uno de los puntos que más ha
complicado la agenda de paz con la
guerrilla del eln en este reinicio de
los diálogos el primer traspié se dio
cuando la guerrilla negó en enero de
este año ser parte de un supuesto DC
bilateral que había pactado el gobierno
con cinco organizaciones criminales
meses más tarde el 29 de marzo una
estructura del grupo criminal emboscó y
asesinó a diez militares en la zona del
catatumbo frontera con Venezuela una
acción Armada que puso en riesgo la
continuidad del proceso hecho que puso
sobre la mesa de diálogos la importancia
del alto el fuego y que marca la agenda
del Tercer ciclo de conversaciones de
paz que se inició en la Habana Cuba la
opinión que tenemos nosotros
es que tenemos que pactar un cese
donde sea totalmente lograble
medible y evaluable
comprometernos ahí que restricciones
vamos a asumir
como es un cese preliminar no es un cese
de fin del conflicto sino preliminar
nos interesa mucho que funcione ciento
por ciento o sea cero errores
con el eln toma relevancia Más aún
cuando la violación de una tregua hizo
que las conversaciones fueran
suspendidas en 2019 en enero y en medio
de una tregua temporal por las
festividades de Fin y principio de año
el eln quebró el alto el fuego con un
atentado suicida dentro de una Escuela
Militar en Bogotá que cobró la vida de
23 personas lo que lleva al entonces
gobierno de Iván Duque a poner pausa a
los acercamientos que habían iniciado
bajo la administración de Juan Manuel a
Santos
a propósito de la conmemoración del Día
Mundial de la libertad de prensa France
24 hace una revisión de la situación en
Centroamérica una de las regiones más
peligrosas para ejercer el periodismo
nuestro reporteros hicieron una
radiografía sobre los casos de Nicaragua
y El Salvador más en el siguiente
informe
es Costa Rica pero también Nicaragua
especialmente para los medios de
comunicación
185 periodistas nicaragüenses han salido
al exilio desde 2018 el caso más
paradigmático es el del diario La prensa
El más antiguo del país con 97 años de
existencia en julio de 2022 toda la
redacción se exilió en Costa Rica Fabián
Medina es su editor un periodista igual
a un arco periodismo y narcotráfico o
algo así un delito grave que se
considera grave ejercer el periodismo en
Nicaragua y se y se percibe como tal
les confiscaron sus instalaciones y
allanaron sus es el caso del foto
reportero Óscar Navarrete después de
cubrir la expulsión de Nicaragua de las
monjas misioneras de la Caridad se me
llevaron equipos de la prensa y equipos
míos personales entre ellos computadoras
tablet laptop cámara fotográficas lentes
y yo vine acá a este país con un iPhone
7 y eso no me detuvo de seguir haciendo
periodismo gráfico la prensa no ha sido
el único medio perseguido en Nicaragua
22 periodistas han perdido la
nacionalidad como Lucía pinedaubau que
además llegó a estar presa cerca de seis
meses antes de salir a Costa Rica su
medio 100% noticias fue confiscado
también su casa hemos sido encarcelado
hemos sido robados nuestros medios de
comunicación nos han robado la
nacionalidad nos han despojado de
nuestros pasaportes
nos han perseguido incluso la
persecución contra la prensa se filtra
por las fronteras centroamericanas como
en El Salvador de nayib bukele El Faro
uno de los referentes en investigación
de América Latina ha decidido mover su
operación administrativa y legal también
a Costa Rica Sergio arauz es uno de sus
directivos también forma parte de la
asociación de periodistas del Salvador
estamos en un momento muy crítico
desde hace algunos años Creo yo que el
bucalismo ha montado un escenario
dispuesto para
restringir la labor de los periodistas y
de los medios Honduras y Guatemala
tampoco escapan de la persecución contra
la prensa convirtiendo a Centroamérica
en una zona roja para aquellos que se
atreven a fiscalizar al poder
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de aquí América pueden enviarnos sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla en la
producción estuvo Andrés doncell y Alba
Santana pueden ver esta emisión y los
anteriores en nuestra página web Franz
24.com
[Música]